اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في اخبار الساعه من
العربيه نستعرض معكم ابرز المستجدات وفي
العناوين
اعضاء يؤيدون انضمام اوكرانيا
في مواجهه موسكو
واشنطن
نزاع في السودان استئناف الوساطه وخارطه
طريق افريقيه لحل الازمه
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقتحم مدينتين ابليس في
الضفه الغربيه ويعتقل 34 فلس
ين واشنطن بمراقبه مناوره لقواتها البحريه
الصيني لقائه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا اكد الامين العام
للناتو
يؤيدون انضمام اوكرانيا لحلف شمال الاطلسي
وقال سلطانه ان جميع اعضاء حلف ايتو
متفقون على ان روسيا لا تمتلك حق الاعتراض
على انضمام الاعضاء الجدد
يتفقوا جميع حلفاء النت على ان القرار
يعود الى اعضاء الحلف واوكرانيا عندما
تصبح عضوا ليس لموسكو حق النقدي ضد توسيع
النيتو اول عمليه نشر للقوات الاضافيه
ستشمل حوالي 700 جندي وهم في طريقهم لكن
هذا بالطبع لا يعني اننا سنتخلى عن الحل
السياسي رسالتنا الى كل من بلغراد
وبرشتينا هي انه يتعين عليهم الانخراط
بحسن نيه في الحوار الذي يسيره الاتحاد
الاوروبي هذا هو السبيل الوحيد للسلام
اكد وزير خارج الامريكيين مواصله حلف
الشمال الاطلسي دعمه لاوكرانيا مضيف ان
ذلك اهم اسباب نجاحك في الدفاع عن اراضيها
وصمودها كما شدد على اهميه تعزيز الحلف
وادخار اعضاء جدد اليه في اشاره للسويد
نتابع
لدينا تركيز قوي على الدعم الذي نستمر في
تقديمه لاوكرانيا للتاكد بانها ستتغلب على
العدوان الروسي المستمر منذ اكثر من عام
ونريد التاكيد ايضا على الاستمرار في
تعزيز وتقويه حلفنا من خلال تطوير خطط
الردع والدفاع ومن خلال استكمال عمليه
ادخال اعضاء جدد للحلف مثل السويد هذه
القضايا الاهم الموجوده على اجندتنا حاليا
قلنا منذ اليوم الاول ماذا سنفعل لدعم
اوكرانيا ولوضع ضغوط على روسيا وتعزيز
حلفنا ولقد طبقنا ما قلنا وسنستمر بفعله
هذا هو اكد رئيس الاوكرانيزيا للاسكي ان
بلاده جاهزه للانضمام لحلف الناتو وقال
لدى وصوله الى مولدوفا لحضور قمه المجموعه
السياسيه الاوروبيه قال ان اوكرانيا تنظر
بل تنتظر ان يكون حلف الناتو مستعدا لقبول
العضويه واضاف انه سيطلب من القاده
المشاركين في القمه دعما لبلاده في ارض
المعركه هذا وافاد مراسل العربيه بعمليه
نزوح مستمره في بيلجورود الروسيه مع
استمرار القصف وواصلت القوات الاوكرانيه
مهاجمه منطقه الحدوديه حيث اعلنها حاكم
المنطقه
اصابه ثمانيه اشخاص في قصف الاوكراني جديد
خلال الليل على بلده شبكنو وقال غلاتكو
انه يتلقى تقارير عن المزيد من الاصابات
جراء الضربات الصاروخيه الاوكرانيه واضرار
لحقت بمنازل وبنايات سكنيه وقذائف اخترقت
الجدران في بعض الحالات
بالعوده مره اولى الى
مولدوفا ينضم الينا حسين اقليم بن مدير
مكتب العربيه في فرنسا اهلا بك حسين
وبدايه ما الذي يميز هذه القمه الاوروبيه
الموسعه في مولدوفا عما سبقها من قمم
اوروبيه حسين
هذه القمه احمد تنعقد على بعد عشرات
الكيلومترات من الحدود
الاوكرانيه هنا في برباكاو القريبه من
كيشيناو عاصمه
وتاريخيه كما قال مصدر في الرئاسه
الفرنسيه رمزيه لانها تبعث برساله دعم قوي
لمولدوفا وتبعث برساله دعم قوي لاوكرانيا
ايضا كانت مولدوفا تقول الرئاسه الفرنسيه
تعرضت سابقا لضغوط روسيه كما ان الهدف من
عقد هذه القمه تقديم دعم قوي لاوكرانيا
وكذلك مناقشه التداعيات الحرب الجاريه
هناك على امن القاره الاوروبيه المحادثات
ستتركز في الحيز الاكبر منها على سبل
تعزيز الدعم العسكري خصوصا اوكرانيا لكنها
ستناقش موضوعات اخرى على راسها امن الطاقه
في القاره الاوروبيه وكذلك الامن
السيبراني القمه تنعقد للمره الثانيه كان
الرئيس ماكرون اطلق فكره انشاء مجموعه
سياسيه اوروبيه في ستراسبور كان اطلق
الفكره قبل عام وعقدت اول قمه لهذه
المجموعه السياسيه الاوروبيه في براج في
اكتوبر من العام الماضي وها هي القمه
الثانيه تنعقد هنا في بولباكو القريبه من
كيشيناو عاصمه
والمؤتمرون هنا كان وصل الرئيس زيلنسكي
قبل قليل وقال لدى وصوله ولقائه برئيسه ان
المجيء الى بولدوفا ليس سهلا وقال ان
المحادثات ستركز على طلب اوكرانيا تقديم
دعم لها في ساحه المعركه احمد
يعني السؤال هنا ايضا لماذا الحاجه لانشاء
هذا الكيان واتحدث عن المجموعه السياسيه
الاوروبيه ما الهدف منها خاصه ان هناك
الكثير من المناسبات التي يمكن ان تجمع
القاده الاوروبيين للتاكيد على هذه النقاط
التي اشرت اليها ايضا
في الواقع الرئيس ماكرون كان حدد الهدف من
انشاء المجموعه الاقتصاديه المجموعه
السياسيه الاوروبيه وهو جمع الدول التي
تؤمن بالقيم نفسها جمع الامم الاوروبيه
التي تؤمن بالقيم نفسها لتسهيل الحوار
السياسي والتعاون فيما بينها حتى لو لم
تكن منضويه الى الاتحاد الاوروبي هناك دول
اوروبيه كثيره تقع في القاره القديمه
لكنها لا تنتسب بعد الى الاتحاد الاوروبي
لان معايير الانتساب ليست متوفره فيها
هناك دول مرشحه فقط لعضويه الاتحاد
الاوروبي وليست منضمه اليه رسميا بعد من
بينها على سبيل المثال مولدوفا واوكرانيا
وكذلك
البوسنه وصربيا والجبل الاسود وايضا
التركيه وهناك دول لم يكن يعني متيسرا حتى
الان ان تحصل على الترشح الاتحاد الاوروبي
كي يحصل تنسيق بين دول الاتحاد السابع
والعشرين والدول الاوروبيه غير المنضويه
ضمن الاتحاد انشات هذه المجموعه السياسيه
الاوروبيه بمبادره من الرئيس الفرنسي قبل
عام والهدف الرئيسي منها تسهيل الحوار
السياسي بين هذه الدول والضمان التعاون
وضمان امن القاره الاوروبيه يعني فيما
تبقى من زمن يعني ماذا نعرف عن اهم
اللقاءات الثنائي الذي يمكن ان تجمع قاده
او القاده المشاركين في هذه القمه على
هامشها طبعا
على هامش القمه ستعقد سلسله من المحادثات
الثنائيه ابرزها سيجمع الرئيس زيلنسكي في
محادثات ثنائيه مع عدد من رؤساء وقاده
الحكومات في دول الاتحاد الاوروبي ابرزهم
رئيسه مولدوفا الدوله المضيفه ولكن ايضا
الرئيس الفرنسي وكذلك مستشار المانيا احمد
شكرا لك بمولوبا كنت معنا حسين قنيبر مدير
مكتب العربي في فرنسا تحيه حسين
مشاهدينا ننتقل مره اخرى الى مدينه
بيلجارود الروسيه ومعنا رؤساء العربي عبر
جواد الرشد اهلا بك عبد الجواد والى اي
مدى يبدو الوضع مخيفا ومقلقا في هذه
المنطقه كما وصفه حكيمها طبعا بسبب القصف
المستمر منذ ايام القصف الاوكراني على
وضواحيها
مرحبا احمد نعم في البدايه لابد من
الاشاره الى اننا نسمع بين الفيينه
والاخرى ضربات في سماء المدينه وضواحيها
يعني هي تبتعد تبتعد عن مركز المدينه
قرابه من خمسه الى عشره كيلومترات
حسب عمل لانظمه الدفاع الجوي ومحاوله
اصطياده
ا احمد يعني نحن الان نتوجه الى الى مركز
للاجئين تم يعني تم تعديله يوميا هو
بالاصل مدينه رياضيه للكره الطائره قامت
سلطات البلاد بتعديله يوم الامس ويستقبل
اليوم قرابه الف لاجئ من تلك المناطق
الحدوديه هي مناطق ساخنه ومعظمهم من مدينه
شبيكنا وضواحيها حتى هذه اللحظه احمد يعني
القرارات التي يتم اتخاذها بما يخص ضمان
سلامه المواطنين نلاحظها
بشكل كبير ابرزها يكمن في ان حاكم الاقليم
بالاعلان عن الغاء الكافه الامتحانات
المدرسيه يعني الطلاب من الصفوف الاخيره
في كل شبكنا والان تعمل حكومه الاقليم على
وضع الي لدخولها الطلاب الجامعات دون اي
امتحانات طبعا تم الاعلان عن اصابه شخصيتي
نتيجه قذائف المدفعيه مصدرها الجانب
الاوكراني في مدينه نوفا بتروفيكا
الارقام النهائيه بما يخص عمليه الاجلاء
تتحدث عن ان الاطفال الذين انطلقوا يومها
مدينه فارونش قد وصلوا الى مركز اليوم
سيتم اسلام شخص ايضا من الاطفال وكبار
السن الى مدينه بانزا ومن المقرر اجلاء
600 شخص اخر من هذه المناطق الحدوديه الى
كابوجا اليوم السبت القادم
ات يعني هل هناك من استراتيجيه واحده
واضحه يمكن ان تتبناها سلطات الروسيه
لاسكاس صوت المدافع القادم من اوكرانيا
خاصه ان هناك انباعا ان الرئيس الروسي
يتلقى اولا باول تقارير ومعلومات حول
مجريات ما يحدث في بيلج وضواحيها
احمد يعني رسميا لا يتم الاعلان حول الرد
الروسي بماذا الموضوع على صعيد التحركات
العسكريه لكن يعني هنا في هذه المدينه
تسمع الضربات التي يقوم بها الجانب الروسي
عند منتصف ليله كل يوم حاكم بالراحه وذهب
بعيدا قبل ايام متحدثه بانه لاشكاش هذه
الضربات الخارجيه المدفعيه والمسيرات من
قبل الجانب الاوكراني التي تنطلق لابد من
السيطره على ذلك الاقليم لكن الجميع يعرف
والتحليلات العسكريه هنا في هذه المنطقه
ترى في خارجه نقطه صعبه جدا لا يمكن
السيطره عليها ببساطه ولا يمكن اسكان هذا
الموضوع لذلك يعني كان الذي حدث يوم امس
والتكومه
الاقليم عدد من السكان ومنحهم الخيار بان
من يرغب الخروج من هناك سنعمل على هذا
الموضوع عليه فقط تقديم الطلب وسنقدم له
المساعده هذا يعني بان حكومه الاقليم
ملقنه بان عمليه الاجلاء لغالبيه سكان
المناطق الحدوديه لابد منها خلال هذا
الوقت الحالي خاصه
الايام الاربع الماضيه يعني تمطر شباكنا
احمد تسمع هذه الضربات بين دقيقه والاخرى
هي
عباره عن صاروخيه او مدفعيه او مسيرات او
شكرا لك الروسيه كنت معنا مراسل العربيه
عبد الجواد تحياتي عبد الجواد
قال امين
اول عمليه نشر للقوات الاضافيه ستشمل
حوالي 700 جندي وهم في طريقهم لكن هذا
بالطبع لا يعني اننا سنتخلى عن الحل
السياسي رسالتنا الى كل من بلغراد وبرشتين
هي انه يتعين عليهم الانخراط بحسن نيه في
الحوار الذي يسيره الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا
هو السبيل الوحيد للسلام
حفظ السلام الدوليه مره اخرى نطلب ان
يستمر اجتماع اليوم بشكل سلمي لاننا
مشهورون بطبيعتنا السلميه والان اطلب من
هؤلاء الافراد ان يرفعوا العلم الصربي
الاكثر جمالا والاكثر اعتزازا نتوقع
احتجاجا سلميا يطالب باقاله رؤساء
البلديات الذين تم تنصيبهم بالقوه وبينما
قد يكون رؤساء البلديات قد تم انتخابهم
بشكل قانوني فاننا لا نعتبر انتخابهم
شرعيا
الاحتجاجات الصربيه سلميه دائما الى ان
يثير احدهم نوعا من التصعيد الصرب شعب
يدافع عن نفسه دائما انهم يدافعون عن
منازلهم وبلداتهم وطريقه حياتهم
نشاطنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
تونس تفتح تحقيقات جديده ضد شخصيات بارزه
بشبهه التامر على امن الدوله
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا من جديد الى تونس حيث
كشفت محاميه تونسيه ان قاضيه تونسيا فتح
تحقيقا جديدا بل تحقيقات جديده تشمل
شخصيات سياسيه بارزه بشبهه التامر على امن
الدوله وقالت المحاميه ناديه شواشي ان من
الشخصيات رئيس الوزراء السابق يوسف الشاهد
وكذلك المديره السابقه لمكتب الرئيس قيس
سعيد وراشد الغنوشي زعيمه حزب النهضه
المعارض بشبهه التعامل على امن الدوله هذا
وتاثير قضيه بعد موجه اعتقالات طالت
الشخصيات معارضه خلال الاشهر القليله
الماضيه هاجمها منتقد سعيد باعتبارها حمله
سياسيه تهدف الاسكات المعارضه وهو ما
ينفيه الرئيس كما اثارت مخاوف حقوقيين من
موجه اعتقالات جديده
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
استعدادها الاستئناف وسطتها في السودان
الا ان الخارجي الامريكيه وضعت جديه اطراف
النزاع السوداني بالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار
كشرط لاستئناف الوساطه حيث جاء ذلك عقب
تعليق الجيش السوداني مشاركته في محادثات
برعايه سعوديه امريكيه لوقف اطلاق النار
متهما قوات الدعم السريع بالفشل في
الايفاء بالتزامتها ومن جانبه وصف المتحدث
باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي في البيت
الابيض جون كيربي وصف انسحاب الجيش
السوداني من مفاوضات الهدنه بالامر
المؤسفير بان القتال في السودان بين الجيش
السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع يجب ان يتوقف
وان المساعدات يجب ان تصل للمتضررين
انه امر مؤسف انسحاب احد اطراف الصراع في
السودان اذ نريد ان يتوقف القتال وان تصل
المساعدات الى المدنيين فمن الصعب عليها
الان ان تصل الى من هم في امس الحاجه
اليها كالغذاء والماء والدواء لذلك من
المؤسف للغايه انهم اختاروا تعليق
المحادثات نريدهم ان يختنموا فرصه السلام
على محمل الجد ونحن بالتاكيد جدون في
المساعده وفي تسهيل هذه المحادثات وعلى
صعيد متصل بالهده السودانيه وجهود الوساطه
اعلن الاتحاد الافريقي عن خارطه طريق لحل
الازمه السودانيه تضمنت مجموعه اجراءات
لتسويه النزاع وقال الاتحاد الافريقي ان
الخارطه تشمل سته بنود منها ان تعمل
الاليه الموسعه المشكله من الاتحاد على
ضمان تنسيق جميع الجهود الاقليميه
والدوليه لحل الازمه السودانيه كما رصت
الخارطه على ضروره الوقف الفوري والدائم
والشامل للاعمال العدائيه والاستجابه الان
الفعاله لتداعيات النزاع وضروره حمايه
المدنيين والبنى التحتيه المدنيه مع
الالتزام الكامل بالقانون الدولي الانساني
وتضمنت ايضا الاعتراف بالدوري المحوري
الذي تلعبه الدول المجاوره المتاثره
بالنزاع واستكمال العمليه السياسيه
الانتقاليه الشامله بمشاركه جميع الاطراف
السودانيه وتشكيل حكومه مدنيه ديمقراطيه
في البلاد هذا ودعت قوى الحريه والتغيير
في السودان الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
لالتزام الصارم ببنود اتفاق الهدنه ووقف
كل الانتهاكات ايضا قوى الحريه والتغيير
في بيان طرفي الصراع على الوقف الفوري
للحرب واعتماد المسار السياسي السلمي
خيارا وحيدا لمعالجه قضايا الازمه الوطنيه
كما طالبت الطرفين باستكمال مفاوضات جده
دون توقف او تعطيل وبكل جديه لوضع حد
الاصتراع والوصول الى وقبل الوصول الى وقف
شامل ودائم لاطلاق النار يضع نهايه للحرب
وبعد ان بين عن وفاتهم مشاهدينا ظهر
القائد الثاني لقوات الدعم السريع عبد
الرحيم في فيديو جديد اكد فيه ان قائد
قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان المعروف
بحميتي بخير ويقاتل مع قواته في الصفوف
الاولى على الارض
الحمد لله بكل امن وامان والان في الصفوف
الاماميه مع قواته والانقبضك
ولكن
بين السكان في بعض بلدات الشمال في
اسرائيل اثارها منشور تم توزيعه على بعض
هذه البلدات خصوصا المحاذيه لحدود
الشماليه ويشرح المنشور سيناريو الحرب
التي يتدرب عليها الجيش هذه الايام تحت
مسمى القبض الساحقه كما يدعو المشهور
السكان في حال نشوب حرب لاخلاء البيوت
ومغادره البلده باسرع وقت حيث سيتم خير
لفتره قصيره اغلاق الطرقات انمي منتخب
سقوط صواريخ مكثفه لا تريح التحرك والتنقل
من جانبهم استبعد مراقبون نشوب حرب في
الوقت الراهن وصلت تساؤلات حول ما اذا كان
المشهور ضمن المناوره التي يقوم بها الجيش
ام انه فعلا يدعو الى الاستعداد
حرض رئيس كتله المعارضه الاسرائيليه
على زعيم الحزب ورئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه
ودعى الى الاطاحه وتشكيل حكومه تنقذ
اسرائيل من احزاب الابتزاز والتشدد الديني
والتطرف السياسي على حد وصفه
تل ابيب اعتبر ان الليكود يقف امام لحظه
تاريخيه وان اسرائيل بحاجه لتشكيل ائتلاف
جديد وباداره مسؤوله وبلا تطرف وتساعد
السلام وتقيم علاقات وثيقه مع الولايات بل
تقيم علاقات وثيقه مع الولايات المتحده
والعالم وتوزع الاعباء وكذلك المداخيل في
اسرائيل بشكل عاجل
نفذ جيش الاسرائيلي فجاه اليوم مشاهدينا
عمليات اقتحام لمدينتين نابلس وطولكرم في
الضفه الغربيه كما كشفت مصادر فلسطينيه
ومكتب ومكتب اعلام الاسرى ان الجيش
الاسرائيلي اعتقل ثلاثه 33 فلسطينيا خلال
عمليات الاقتحام هذه فيما رد عدمي
الفلسطينيين على عمليات الاقتحام باقدامهم
على ادرام نيران بنقاط عسكريه تابعه للجيش
الاسرائيلي على مدخل بلده عزون شارقه
قلقيليه وفي حي عين اللوزه ببلده سلوان
جنوب المسجد الاقصى كذلك
قالت الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه ان
ايران ضاعفت مخزونها من اليورانيوم المخصه
باكثر من ثلاث وعشرين مره عن ما كان عليه
وقت الاتفاق وقت الاتفاق النووي في 2015
وكانت الوكاله ان ايران زادت مخزونها من
اليورانيوم
من افي طهران السعيا الى حيازه القنبله
النوويه وبذلك يكون اجمالي مخزون ايران
اليورانيوم المخصب يقدر باكثر من
4744 كيلوغراما في الثلاثه في الثالث عشر
من مايو الجاري في حين ان الحد المسموح به
في الاتفاق يبلغ اكثر من 200 كيلو جرامين
رفضت السلطات التركيه مشاهدينا منحى
المصري الاخواني المدام بالاعدام وجدي
غنيم جنسيتها وقال انه رغم فرحته بفوز
رئيس تركيا الطيب اردوغان بولايه رئاسيه
جديده الا انه حزين بسبب رفض انقره منحه
الجنسيه هذا وعلمت العربيه ان السلطات
التركيه رفضت منحى الجنسيه لعدد من شباب
وعناصر الاخوان بينهم اعلاميون وصحفيون
ودون تقديم اضاحات او مبررات يذكر ايضا
مشاهدينا ان محكمه الجنايات القاهره قد
حكمت في العام 2017 على وجد غنيم بالاعدام
شنقا وكذلك بعض المتهمين معه من عناصر
جماعه الاخوان بتهمه تاسيس خليه اطلق
عليها خليه وجد غنيم لارتكاب اعمال
ارهابيه وتفجيرات في مصر
اعلنت الامم المتحده عن بدء عمليات انقاذ
ناقله النفط صافر العالقه قبال سواحل
اليمن والمحمله باكثر من مليون برميل من
الخام ما يشكل خطرا كبيرا على البيئه
نتابع انفراج مرتقب لازمه تجاوزت مدتها
سبعه اعوام بعد اعلان الامم المتحده وصول
سفينه دعم لخزان صافر الا ان الانفراج
امامه عقبه نقص التمويل اما الحكومه
اليمنيه فقد تحدثت عن سعيها لوضع حل
للكارثه بعد سنوات من تعنت الحوث ورفضه
للحلول الاقل كلفه لخزان صافر وبفضل جهود
الحكومه والامم المتحده والشركاء الدوليين
بدات اليوم اولى خطوات عمليه الانقاذ
عمليه الانقاذ مكونه من مرحلتين وفق الامم
المتحده وتقدر تكلفتها بنحو 142 مليون
دولار لتامين نقل النفط من صافر لسفينه
الانقاذ الا ان الامم المتحده
اشارت الى حاجتها لاربعه عشر مليون دولار
باكمال المرحله الحاليه
بين صنعاء وعدم ظل مرضى السرطان ابناء
مارب والنازحون فيها يتنقلون لتشخيص المرض
وعلاجه وفي ظل تزايد عدد المصابين تم
افتتاح وحده لمعاريه الاورام تخفف على
المرضى اعباء السفر وحده المشاهدين تفتقر
للكثير من الامكانيات لكنها تمثل نواه
لافتتاح مركز متخصص لعلاج الاورام بحسب
السلطات المحليه نتابع تفاصيل في سن
الاربعه اعوام يعاني الطفل يعقوب من سرطان
الدم ومع تلقيه جرعات كيماويه في صنعاء
عادت حركته الطبيعيه بعد اشهر من فقدان
الامل في التعافي يعقوب طفل من النازحين
في مارب يعاني الالاف منهم امراضا مزمنه
وحالات سرطان متفاوته الخطوره في ظل غياب
كلي لعياده كشف ومعالجه السرطان خلال
الفتره الماضيه
فحوصات في كل المختبرات اللي موجوده في
مارب ما توصل مده اربع شهور
المريض وفحصه وقبل اعطاء الجرعه
وتحضيره للعلاج اعطال جرعه التمهيديه قبل
العلاج الكيماوي ثم بعد ذلك يتم مراقبته
واعطاء العلاج الكيماوي لدينا احصائيه
اوليه من محافظه مارب يحول ما يقارب 120
مريض سرطان خلال الفتره السابقه الاشهر
الماضيه
فهناك حاجه ملحه وضروريه في محافظه مارب
لا يوجد وحده او عياده حتى عياده تخصصيه
لعلاج السرطان
127 حاله من مرضى السرطان في مديريات مارب
الثلاث المجاوره لشركات الاستكشافات
والانتاج النفطي رصدتهم منظمه محليه فيما
توفي المئات وربما الالاف من الحالات في
مخيمات النزوح قبل تشخيص الاورام محمود
الحميدي العربيه مارب
اتهمت وزاره الدفاع الصينيه الولايات
المتحده بتدخل ومراقبه مناوره بحريه في
بحر الصين الجنوبي قبل حادثه اقتراب
مقاتله جويه من طائره استطلاع امريكيه
وقال بيان صاد عن الوزاره الى القوات
الجويه الصينيه تعاملت مع طائره الاستطلاع
الامريكيه وفقا للقوانين واللوائح وبشكل
احترافي ودعت الدفاع الصيني الولايات
المتحده هي التزام الصارم بالقوانين
الدوليه ذات الصله لمنع الحوادث في البحر
والجو وتحمل العواقب كذلك
اعرب وزير الدفاع الامريكي خلال زياره الى
طوكيو عن اسفه لرفض نظيره الصيني
الاجتماعي به هذا الاسبوع لا سيما في ضوء
المناورات الاستفزازيه التي قامت بها
مؤخرا مقاتلات صينيه قرب طائره عسكريه
امريكيه كما ذكرنا قبل قليل وحذر انه بعد
عمليات الاعتراض هذه زاد خلقه من احتمال
وقوع حادث قد يخرج سريعا عن السيطره
مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد الفاصل
عضو في مجلس الشيوخ الايطالي في خطاب كتبه
شات
اعضاء النيتو يؤيدون انضمام اوكرانيا
لحل الازمه
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقتحم مدينتي نابلس
وطولكرم في الضفه الغربيه ويعتقل 34
فلسطينيا
تتهموا واشنطن بمراقبه مناوره لقواتها
البحريه
الصيني لقائه
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في سباق الجمهوريين نحو
تسميه مرشح الانتخابات الرئاسيه الامريكيه
لعام 2024 يعتزم نائب الرئيس السابق وحاكم
لدخول السباق الاسبوع المقبل حيث كشفت
مصادر ان الذي كان مستشارا لحمله ترامب في
2016 قبل ان يصبح من اشد منتقدي سيعلن
رسميا عن حملته لعام 2024 في السادس من
الشهر الجهري فيما قالت مصادر مطلع لروتاز
من المقرر ان يدخل السباق ضد رئيسه السابق
في السابع من يونيو وظيفه ان حاكم ولايه
نورثى
يعتزم ايضا دخول السباق في نفس اليوم
وبحسب استطلاعات الراي فان ترامبا لا يزال
يتمتع بفارق كبير في ميدان الحزب الجمهوري
الذي يضم الان اكثر من عشره مرشحين معلنين
او محتمرين فيما يعد حاكم فلور داروين
ديسانس الذي دخل السباق الاسبوع الماضي
الاقرب في منا فسته وفقا لاستطلاعات الراي
الامريكيه من حمله اعلاميه ممنهجه تهدف
لعرقله مرشحه على انه خطر على الحريه
الفكريه والاكاديميه في الولايات المتحده
اليكم التفاصيل ان الصعود الصاروخيه
لشعبيه روندسانس منافس ترامب على قياده
الحزب الجمهوري قد اربكت ديمقراطيين مثلما
اربكت ترامب
فوكس نيوز تحذر من حمله اعلاميه مسبقه
تشنها وسائل واعلام تحاول عرقله ديسانتس
باشاعه انه اكثر خطرا على الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه من منافسه ترامب مستدله بعدد من
المقابلات والتغريدات التي برزت مؤخرا من
صحفيين ديمقراطيين
مقربه من الجمهوريين تصف ديسانتس بانه
مستقبل الحزب الشاب الاكثر نجاحا وشعبيه
في البلاد وخير وريث للترامبيه القويه
سبق وان تحدث عن ميله لاتخاذ تشريعات
صارمه ضد عدد من القضايا التي يعتبرها
الديمقراطيون حريه مثل قضايا الضرائب
والاجهاض والمهاجرين والتعليم وحمل السلاح
قالت مصادر في حلف شمال الاطلسي الناتو ان
اسم رئيس الوزراء الاسباني فيدروسان طرح
على طاوله لتعيينه امين العام لحلف خلاف
خلافا
غير ان استبعد نفسه كبديل محتمل التفاصيل
[موسيقى]
يدرس حلف الناتو تعيين رئيس الوزراء
الاسباني بيدروس امينا عاما للحلف خلفا
لامينه الحالي يانستولتنبرغ في مارس
الماضي كان بيدرس انشاز يفكر في رئاسه
دوره كامله لمجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي
استبعد نفسه كبديل محتمل الا ان مصادر في
الحلف قالت ان اسمه تم تداوله على الطاوله
بدا سانشيز حياته السياسيه عام 2004 كعضو
في مجلس مدينه مدريد
انتخب لمجلس النواب الاسباني عام 2009
وعام 2014 انتخب امينا عاما لحزب العمال
الاشتراكي الاسباني
قد حزبه الى الفوز في انتخابات عام 2019
وتراس الحكومه الاسبانيه عام 2020
[موسيقى]
اثار ايلون ماسك رئيس التنفيذي لشركه تسلا
دهشه بزيارته الاولى لبكين منذ ثلاث سنوات
ولقائه وزير الخارجيه الصيني في اجتماع
وصفه الخبراء بعالي المخاطر معتبرين ان
زياره ماسك تاتي في مساء للدخول على خط
التفاهمات بين واشنطن وبكين
الشركات الامريكيه الكبرى دخلت على خط
التسويه مع الصين لنزع فتيل الفتنه بين
اكبر اقتصادين في العالم في وقت يحتدم
الصراع بين واشنطن وبيكين زاد من حدته
حادث بالون التجسس الشهير والتوترات حول
شكوك امريكيه بتجسس الصين على واشنطن
والعالم من خلال تيك توك ومع وجود مؤشرات
قليله على المصالحه وبحجه ان للقوى العظمى
مصلحه مشتركه في استمرار التعاون حتى
ايلون ماسك الرئيس التنفيذي لشركه تسلا
رحاله في الصين والتقى وزير خارجيتها وهي
احدث عوده لرئيس تنفيذي امريكي كبير الى
الصين والتي اعتبرها الخبراء عاليه
المخاطر في وقت تشتد التراشقات الامريكيه
الصينيه الى اعلى مستوياتها وعلى كافه
الصعد
شركات كبرى سبقت ماسك الى خط المصالحه
كابل وستاربكس وغيرها في دليل واضح على
حاجه السوق الامريكي الى الصين في النمو
فالمصالح الامريكيه والصينيه يراها
الخبراء لا تنفصل عن بعضها البعض
وبمازل عن توجهات قاده البلدين في اداره
الصراع القائم سيستمر الخصمان بالاعتماد
على بعضهما البعض مهما اشتد الصراع بينهما
مع ادراك كبرى الشركات الامريكيه اهميه
الصين في النمو الاقتصادي العالمي ولعدم
حدوث انفجار كبير كارثي قد يوجه اقتصاد
العالم الى مسار لا تحمد عقبه
بالعوده مره اخرى الى التوترات على الحدود
الاسرائيليه اللبنانيه ينضم الينا مدير
مكتب العربيه في فلسطين زياد حلب اهلا بك
زياده وبدايه زياده كيف يقرا هذا التزامن
للمناورات العسكريه الاسرائيليه مع
التهديدات من امكانيات اندلاع حرب على
الجبهه الشماليه في اسرائيل
طبعا رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي بنيامين
نتنياهو قبل بعض الوقت انضم الى المناورات
اشرف عليها مع وزير الدفاع وقادت الجيش
والطلعه على امرين الامر الاول هو سير
المناورات والامر الاخر كان عمليا سيناريو
استهداف منشات بعيده الكل يعرف ما هو
المقصود طبعا يقصدون المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه لكن ما من شك حتى عندما يقول
الجيش الاسرائيلي بان المناورات روتينيه
مجدوله لهذا العام لكن بدون ادنى شك بان
قد يكون هناك ارتباطا وثيقا بالمعطيات على
الجبهه الشماليه التي باتت مقلقه بالنسبه
للاسرائيليين في الاونه الاخيره بينما
نتحدث هناك توتر ميداني على الحدود
الشماليه عمليا في منطقه لا تبعد كثيرا عن
هنا اسرائيل تحفر خنادق عمليا على امتداد
المناطق
المناطق الحدود مع لبنان وخاصه داخل مزارع
شبع المحتله عمليا بدات بحفر هذه الخنادق
هناك توتر مع الجيش اللبناني تحديدا وقوات
اليونيفال تفصل بين الجانبين بالاضافه الى
ذلك يعني هناك حال تاهب لا علاقه لها
بالمناورات موجوده على امتداد الجبهه
الشماليه دبابات في المناطق المختلفه
وطبعا عند الحدود مع لبنان طيب زياد يعني
فيما يتعلق بهذه المخاوف الاسرائيليه من
التصعيد مع حزب الله هو سوريا الى اي مدى
هي ايضا مرتبطه
بالمواجهه الاوسع مع ايران وببرنامجها
النووي
هذا صحيح جدا يعني الاجابه هي في صلب هذا
السؤال لان عمليا المستجد ولهذا سمعت رئيس
اركان الجيش الاسرائيلي والقاده العسكريين
والامنيين في اسرائيل يحذرون من ان
اسرائيل قد تضطر الى ضرب المنشات النوويه
الايرانيه لم ياتي ذلك من فراغ عمليا
اسرائيل باتت تدرك بان ايران توشك ان
تستكمل عمليه نقل البرنامج النووي برمبته
وامورا اخرى الى باطن الارض بعمق 80 مترا
واكثر من ذلك في جبال الزقروس عمليا بحيث
ان حتى
القنابل الذكيه الامريكيه الخارقه
للتحصينات لا يمكنها ان تخترقها مثل هذه
التحصينات بمعنى قد يصبح البرنامج نووي
الايراني في في معزل او في من ان عن
الضربات وهذا بالنسبه لاسرائيل خط احمر
جديد لهذا اصبحت نافذه العمل العسكري صديق
وعندما تفكر اسرائيل في
نعود مره اخرى الى مدينه الروسيه ومعنى
مراسل العربيه عبود الرشد وجوله داخل احد
مراكز اللاجئين مرحبا بك عبد الجواد من
جديد واليك الكلمه والصوره
مرحبا
مرحبا احمد يعني نحن الان في احد مراكز
اللاجئين الذين يعني الذين جاؤوا الى هنا
الى مركز مدينه
القائمون على هذا المكان يتحدثون
اللاجئين تصل الى قرابه الالف شخص ياتون
من ساعات الصباح الباكر بعد الهجمات
الكبيره التي يتعرض لها هذا الاقليم يعني
الغالبيه هم من النساء من الاطفال من كبار
السن كما نلاحظ بان عنصر الشباب نوعا ما
هو مختفي هناك بعض الاصابات يعني لدى
البعض منهم طبعا
كما نلاحظ بان عمليه الوضع والتدقيق
الامني هي يعني تجري بشكل كبير الاشخاص
الذين يرتدون الملابس الزرقاء هم متطوعون
يعملون مع هؤلاء الاشخاص طبعا هناك تواجد
لعناصر الامن في المكان لا يمكن الوصول
اليهم بشكل مباشر على هذه الجهه احمد
هناك يعني كما نلاحظ
تواجد اشخاص من مختلف الفئات العمريه ذلك
هو مركز الاستقبال الذي يقدم الخدمات
الطبيه بالمناسبه احمد هذا المكان هو صاله
رياضيه للكره الطائره تم تعديله واعاده
تنسيقه سريعا خلال اليومين الماضيين
لاستقبال اللاجئين احمد هذه طبعا هي كبيره
الاطباء في هذا المركز يعني يمكننا طرح
سؤال عليها ما هي يعني الخدمات الطبيه
التي يحتاجها القادمون من تلك المناطقتي
تتحدث كبيره الاطباء احمد عن ان الاشخاص
الموجودين هنا يعانون من قلق كبير بسبب
الاوضاع الامنيه في المناطق التي يعيشون
بها تتحدث عن ان معظمهم لم ينم خلال
الايام القليله الماضيه بسبب الضربات وهذا
هو يعني اكثر شيء يحتاجونه هو الدعم
المعنوي في البدايه ويعني محاوله الخروج
من الوضع الذي كانوا فيه احمد بالعوده الى
هذا المركز هو واحد من سبعه مراكز اقيم في
مركز بيليجراد في مركز المدينه للوضع فيها
امن نوعا ما حتى هذه اللحظه باستثناء
الضربات التي تسمع في سماء المدينه لكن
على ما يبدو ان حكومه هذا الاقليم متجهه
نوعا ما احمد نحو اخلاء المناطق الحدوديه
تبعا للوضع الصعب الذي يملا ويطال القرى
الحدوديه في هذا الاقليم هو شريط حدودي
طويل احمد يمتد قرابه 400 كيلومتر لكنه
يتعرض من الجهتين الغربيه والجنوبيه ل
متقنه كما سماها البعض وانصحها التعبير هي
الصاروخيه مدفعيه بالمسيرات وطبعا دخل
عليها عنصر صواريخ اغراض ورجمات الصواريخ
التي اصبحت تلعب دورا محوري في اصابه
الاهداف في هذه المناطقة
يعني اود توضيحه منك حولها يعني كيف يمكن
لهذا المركز ان يشكل حمايه لهؤلاء
اللاجئين يعني هو متواجد في نفس المنطقه
التي تتعرض لقصف مستمر وهو كما اشرت عباره
عن صاله الرياضيه اذن هل يعد ذلك مكانا
امنا بالنسبه لهؤلاء اللاجئين
احمد يعني هذه الصلاه هي تقع في داخل مركز
بيل جراند ومثلها سبع مباني تستقبل
اللاجئين داخل المدينه السلطات يتحدثون عن
وجود انظمه للدفاع الجوي يمكنها اعتراض
المسيرات الثقيله يمكنها اعتراض الضربات
الصاروخيه لكن ضربات المدفعيه لا تصل الى
هذا المكان باعتبارها تبعد مسافه كافيه عن
مناطق الحدوديه لكن على العموم يعني كما
يتحدث القائمون سقف هذا المبنى هي من
الترسانه يعني وفيها يعني اجهزه حمايه على
سقف هذا المكان يعني لمنع حدوث اي ضربات
لكن في النهايه هي صاله رياضيات تستقبل
قرابه 5000 شخص خلال المباريات الرياضيه
للكره الطائره يعني وهي مجهزه بشكل كبير
لاستقبال هذه الاعداد الهائله لذلك طبعا
كان خيار القائمون على مراكز اللاجئين في
روسيا ان كانت من جهه دانيتك ومن جهات
اخرى هي الصلاه الرياضيه التي يمكن من
خلالها استقبال عدد كبير من السكان وتوفير
اساليب الحمايه لهم ودائما عبد الجواز
جاهز بالاجابات المقنعه شكرا لك من جديد
بالقرود الروسيه مراسل العربيه جواد الرشد
وكنت معنا في جوله داخل احد مراكز اللاجئ
تحياتي عبد الجواد
قبل السابع مشاهدينا من حلول عيد الاضحى
تعاني الاسواق المصريه من ارتفاعات كبيره
في اسعار اللحوم الحمراء التفاصيل في
التقرير التالي
يجلس المعلم سامح الجزار امام محله منتظرا
للزبائن الذين تراجعت اعدادهم بشده خلال
الفتره الاخيره اسعار اللحوم الحمراء قفزت
الى ارقام غير مسبوقه سامح وغيره من
الجزارين يؤكدون انهم يتضررون بسبب هذه
الاسعار التي لا دخل لهم في تحديدها الشغل
ما عادش ربع الاول
يعني الجزارين كلها كله بيعاني من قله
الشغل وما الغلا
فالجزار اليومين دول يعني ماسك نفسه شويه
طبعا ده مش السعر الطبيعي بتاعها يعني ده
عدم توافرها المسؤولون الحكوميون يرجعون
ارتفاع اسعار اللحوم لعدد من الاسباب
بدايه من تعطل سلاسل الغذاء العالميه بسبب
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه وصولا الى تبعات
الحرب في السودان التي عطلت عمليات
الاستيراد الحكومه قررت مضاعفه استيراد
كميات اكبر من اللحوم من عدد من الاسواق
الافريقيه والدوليه خلال المرحله المقبله
الكثير من المواطنين يتجهون لشراء اللحوم
من المنافذ التابعه للدوله باسعار اقل انا
عشان السعر رخيص عن الجزارين اللي بره انا
جايه اخد اللحمه من هنا حلوه وارخص من
الجزارين بره هل فتره الماضيه شهدت اغلاق
عدد من محال الجزاره استجابه لدعوات
المقاطعه بينما ينتظر المصريون عيد الاضحى
تبقى مساله شراء اللحوم الحمراء هاجسا
للكثيرين الذين يتفاجئون بارتفاعات شبه
يوميه في اسعارها احمد عثمان العربيه
القاهره اذا مشاهدينا قرا احد اعضاء مجلس
الشيوخ الايطالي امام زملائه خطابا كتبه
برنامج
وذلك بعدما كان سلطته روما حضرت مؤقتا هذه
الاداه لمخاوف تتعلق بخصوصيه البيانات قبل
ان تعيد السماح بها ولفت العضو انتباه
بقيه الاعضاء بعد انتهاء خطابه حيث اكد
الحضور ان الخطاب لم يكن من اعداد الذكاء
البشري بل كان النتاجا خوارزميه ذكاء
اصطناعي
كشفت صحيح
علنا في محاوله للمصالحه معهم ويشير هذا
الخبر مشاهدينا الى تغير موقفهما تجاه
عائله الامير هاري وخاصه بعدما اطلق
كلاهما هاري اوميجا النارا مجازيا على
الاسره المالكه البريطانيه واتهمها بالكذب
والعنصريه خلال تصوير مسلسل وثائقي على
منصه نتفليكس
مشاهدينا بقي ان نذكر بابرز العناوين
اعضاء النيتو يؤكدون بل يؤيدون انضمام
اوكرانيا
في مواجهه موسكو
جديه طرفي النزاع في السودان استئناف
الوساطه وخارطه الطريق الافريقيه لحل
الازمه
الجيش الاسرائيلي يقتحم مدينتي نابلس
وطولكرم في الضفه الغربيه ويعتقل 34 فلس
ين تتهم واشنطن بمراقبه مناوره لقواتها
البحريه
هذه الساعه الاخباريه
[موسيقى]
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات